حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء فايز اذا
اوكرانيا تتحدث عن ضوء اخضر غربي لكي
تستطيع شان هجمات على القرم ما شكل
المعركه باعتقادك التي ستتخذها هذه
الهجمات على
القر يعني هذه الهجمات هي بدات منذ اشهر
بدات في الهجوم على جسر كيرش اولا والهجوم
الثاني على جسم الجسر كيرش هناك هجمات
متتاليه
متصاعده سواء على منطقه سيف ستوبر على بعض
محطات الرادار بعض قواعد الامداد اللوجستي
اذا دعيني اقول خلال الفتره الماضي هناك
تواتر في الغارات ولكن يتباين عدد هذه
الغارات والفاصل الزمني بينها وهذا مرتبط
بالظروف الاستخباريه والقدرات على ارسال
ال المسيرات او استخدام صواريخ ظل العاصفه
البريطانيه من قبل سلاح الجو الاوكراني
اذا التصعيد سيكون مستمر ومتواتر بهذه
القدرات الطيارات المسيره استخدام صواريخ
او استخدام المسيرات
البحريه اما الحديث عن معارك بريه لا يزال
الحديث مبكر جدا لماذا لان ال لا تزال
هناك مسافه طويله
بين مواقع
القوات
الاوكرانيه في اور خف او ما حولها وما بين
ملتبل وبردي انسك المسافه 80 م تبعد
القوات الكانيه عن مليت اوبل و1 ر عن
شواطئ بحر اسوف الان الحديث عن تقدم يقاس
بمئات الامتار بمساحه كيل م مربع 4 م مربع
اذا لا يزال الحدي
يول على الاخترا الحالي في منط زج اذا قيض
له ان ينجح كيف يمكن لروسيا ان تتعاطى مع
هذا المعطى الجديد المتمثل بالضوء الاخضر
لاوكرانيا بشن هجمات على
القرم يعني الضوء الاخضر هو اصلا العمليات
العسكريه في القرم كانت وفي الداخل الروسي
هي سابقه على الضوء الاخضر فالضوء الاخضر
هو جاء اعلانا
عن بعض الاجراءات العسكريه يعني في سابقا
وكن الا يعني الضوء الاخضر لواء فايز ان
هذه الضربات على القرم ستتكفل
يختلف عن
السابق انا قلت يعني الان يجب ان نحدد ما
هي الامكانات التي يمكن توظيفها انا قلت
ان الهجمات هي متواتره تتباين في شدتها او
في الفواصل الزمنيه بناء على معطيات
ميدانيه ولكن
الان من حيث المبدا القرم تعتبر في من
وجهه نظر القانون الدولي اراضي اوكرانيه
منذ عام
1953 عندما قدمها ريشوف هديه الى اوكرانيا
من اجل التعايش ما بين الاوكران والروس في
تلك في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي القانون
الدولي يعتبرها اراضي محتله والرئيس باي
وغيره جميعهم تحدثوا عن حق اوكرانيا في
قصف المناطق المحتله اذا هنا الجديد هو
التسميه استخدم لفظ شبه جزيره القرم في
التصريحات انما بالاصل هي الكل وافق على
هذا الاجراء العسكري شكرا لك اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
عمان